es un regreso triunfal a la cámara de
Tennessee para el legislador demócrata
Justin Jones con el puño y la cabeza en
alto marchó con sus partidarios hasta el
Capitolio del estado de Tennessee y juró
su cargo En la escalinata exterior antes
de entrar en la cámara de representantes
cantando canciones de la época de los
Derechos civiles en Estados Unidos
quiero dar la bienvenida al pueblo a la
casa del pueblo quiero dar la bienvenida
a la democracia a la casa del pueblo que
el jueves pasado miembros de este cuerpo
intentaron crucificar la democracia pero
hoy estamos de pie como testigos de una
resurrección
el legislador afroamericano fue
expulsado hace solo unos días junto con
el demócrata Justin pearson por
participar en una protesta por el
control de armas en el hemiciclo de la
cámara una representante blanca que
también se unió a ellos se libró de la
expulsión por un voto lo que desató
críticas de parcialidad racial la escena
se produjo después de que un tirador
matara a tres niños y tres adultos en
una escuela de Nashville el 27 de marzo
los republicanos argumentaron que Jones
había violado las normas de decoro de la
cámara comparándolo a él y a los demás
legisladores con los alborotadores del
Capitolio de Estados Unidos en 2021 la
expulsión atrajo la atención nacional y
fue criticada por los demócratas Según
la ley de Tennessee las asambleas
legislativas de los condados pueden
cubrir los escaños vacantes con
representantes interinos hasta que se
celebra una elección especial el lunes
el consejo Metropolitano de Nashville
votó 36 a 0 a favor de restituir a Jones
como representante interno de su
Distrito la comisión del Condado de
Shelby también considerará la
posibilidad de volver a nombrar a Justin
pearson para su distrito de Memphis en
una votación que tendrá lugar el
miércoles